اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونص معكم ابرز المستجدات
وفي العناوين
ترامب يواجه ثلاثه وثلاثين اتهاما امام
محكمه نيويورك ومحاميه يعتبر قضيته
اضطهادا سياسيا
هو رئيس الدوما يتهم الغرب بتحويل
اوكرانيا الى دوله ارهابيه
ظاهره امريكيه في سوريا تستهدف قياديا
كبيرا في تنظيم داعش خطط لتنفيذ هجمات في
اوروبا
الصين تردد بلقاء رئيس مجلس وبالامريكي
رئيسه تايوان في كاليفورنيا وتحذر من
التداعيات
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من نيويورك
وقضيه محاكمه الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب وسط استنفار امني كبير في
محيط محكمه نيويورك اذ يمثل رئيس الامريكي
السابق ترامبا عصر اليوم الثلاثاء امام
محكمه منحاه لابلاغه رسميا بتوجيه تهم
جنائيه اليه في قضيه دفع اموال لممثله
الاباحيه بغرض شراء صمتها وذلك في حدث غير
مسبوق لرئيس امريكي السابق وكانت ترامب قد
وصل مساء الاثنين يونيون
وقبل وصوله كتب ترامب على منصته للتواصل
الاجتماعي هذه حمله اضطهاد دوله التي كانت
عظيمه في يوم من الايام تتجه الى الجحيم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
انه سيتم توجيه الاتهام اليه في ثلاث
وثلاثين تهمه في محكمه نيويورك اليوم
الثلاثاء واعتبر ترامب ان المدعي العام في
منحاه سرب لائحه الاتهام لوسائل اعلام كما
اشار رئيس الامريكي السابق اشار الى انه
لا توجد تغيرات او مفاجات او انه غير مذنب
مؤكدا ايضا انه يجب توجيه رائحه اتهام
نفسه حيث تسربت محتويات لوائح الاتهام
المعلقه الى الصحافه وردا على مطالب وسائل
اعلام بالسماح لها ببث المحاكمه على
الهواء
اكد القاضي اخواني الذي يتراس الجاسه
اليوم ان محاكمه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب لن تداعى الهواء مباشره القادم
على اهميه هذه المحاكمه التاريخيه ومؤكدا
انه سيتم السماحه فقط لبعض المصورين
بالتقاط صور في قاعه المحكمه قبل بدء
الاجراءات رسميا
هذا وافاد محامي الدفايه عن الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب جو تاكوبينا
ان موكله يعتزم اعلان براءته امام محكمه
نيويورك وانشاء الوحيده الذي سيتم الاجابه
عليه على الفور هو انهم سيقولون بانه غير
مذنب على حد وصفه واضافت كوبينا ان تقييم
ودراسه لائحه الاتهام وتحديد الاجراءات
بعد تلقي جميع المعلومات ستستغرق وقتا كما
يعتقد محامي ترامب ان قضيه سخيفه من نواحي
كثيره وانها تعد اضطهادا سياسيا على حد
وصفه وشددا على ان القضيه تدخل منطقه
خطيره حيث السياسه لها تاثير على نظام
العداله وتستخدم النيابه العامه كسلاح
ايضا
مشاهدينا من باريس انضموا الينا الباحث في
الشؤون القانونيه في راس الحاج يحيى اهلا
بك استاذ فراس معنا في هذه النشره التقرير
الاعلاميه تتحدث عن اكثر من 30 اتهاما
باحتيال تجاري الى صحه تعبير هذا عن قضيه
الممثل الاباحيه
كيف ترى موقف الرئيس السابق
القانوني وفق هذه المعطيات
احياتي لحضرتك سيدي الكريم
حقيقه هذه السهمه الى الان
يعني اخبار تم ايراد من مصادر المطلعه لكن
بضوء هذه المصادر وهذه المعلومات ما
يمكنها قوله بان تهم الموجه الان الى
الرئيس الامريكي الساده تتضمن على الاقل
يعني في هذه القضيه مخالفه القانون
الانتخابي والتحايل الانظمه هاتين
السهمتين لوحدهما وحدهما كافيتين للحكم
عليه بالسجن والغرام باليوم عليه الذهاب
الى القرن المحكمه لتنظيم محضر يعني اجراء
اجراءات القانونيه المجتمع معهم اخر
والمتمثله بتوقيف توقيف يعني
نحن مضطرون للذهاب لمؤتمر الصحفي لوزير
الخارجي الامريكي
من جديد
تمويل الحرب او تمويل الشعب وبالتالي لا
يوجد ان كان
هذا ما تقول اليه الامور فلن يبقى مالا
للشعب في روسيا وهناك كثر تاثروا بحرب
بوتين على اوكرانيا
لابد من محاسبه وهناك جهود دبلوماسيه يمكن
ان تتوصل الى سلام دائم وعادل وكما ناقشنا
التعاون غير المسبوق بين اوروبا والولايات
المتحده في قطاع الطاقه
ونحن نلتزم بشكل مشترك
والحيلوله دون هذه الكارثه وبناء المناعه
وايضا ايجاد السبل للتوصل الى الطاقه
المتجدده وايجاد فرص العمل باقل كلفه على
لكل شعوب
طرفي الاطلسي وكذلك فهي فرصه لتسريع
التقدم خلال السنه الماضيه
فالولايات المتحده واوروبا تعاوننا باكثر
بشكل غير مسبوق في مجال الطاقه
[موسيقى]
في مناطق مختلفه نعمل فيها ونلصق فيها
بحيث نحدث فرقا من اثيوبيا الى الشرق
الاوسط وكل هذه المناطق في العالم التنسيق
بين الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي
عظيم واعظم مما كان عليه في السابق واخيرا
في النقاش كنا نركز على تحت
تعزيزي ديمقراطيتنا والقيم الديمقراطيه
وناقشنا
وسيكون هناك قمه الديمقراطيه والعلاقه بين
الولايات المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي هي
الاكثر
شموليه
ونشطه وفعاله ونعمل من اجل مستقبلا امن
لشعوب ضفتي المحيط الاطلسي شكرا لكم
معكم في متابعه لهذا المؤتمر الصحفي لوزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه الشؤون الخارجيه كما
اتبعنا يقول لدينا فرص كبيره للتعاون مع
الاتحاد الاوروبي في مجال الطاقه
تتشاركان القلق بشان دعم الصين لروسيا
يقول على الصين واجب اخلاقي بالعمل على
انهاء الحرب في اوكرانيا وليس دعم روسيا
ويقول ايضا ان الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده
الملتزمتان والملتزمان باستمرار الدعم
لاوكرانيا ونشر روسيا لاسلحه نوويه في
بيلاروسيا تهديد المباشر للامن
الاوروبيكم بمجدي التفاصيل حول
مره اخرى مشاهدينا الى ضيفنا من باريس
الباحث في الشؤون القانونيه فراس الحاج
يحيى اهلا بك السيد فراس من جديد كنت
اتحدث قبل هذا المؤتمر الصحفي عن مدى
خطوره هاتين التهمتين وهي تهمه التحايل او
الاحتيال التجاري الموجه لترامب ايضا الى
تهمه الممثل الامريكيه
قلت انها كافيتان
لسجن ترامب لكن الرجل يبدو واثقا ومحامه
كذلك ويبدو انه يستند على دوافع كبيره
ربما تحميه من هذه المحاكمه ما الذي يمكن
ان يستند عليه في تقديرك
بالبدايه يعني تفضلت به الى شك لان هذه
القضيه ليست قضيه قانونيه بحث وانها قضيه
تحمل شقين عن الشق القانوني والشق السياسي
وبالتالي يتم استثمارها من قبل
الخصومه وايضا من قبل
الانتخابيه والرئيس حمله الانتخابيه
بالتالي يستند عليه الرئيس وحتى محامين في
ان هذه الادعاء او في قوله بان هذا
الادعاء
وبان يعني القضيه قضيه سياسيه وبهذه
التطور من الناحيه القانونيه الى يعني
تعاطف الشعبي او التعاطف الشارع او مؤيدين
الرئيس ترامب اما اذا كنا نتحدث عن عن
الناحيه القانونيه والامور القانونيه
بتصوري واعتقادي الشخصي بان ابكي عن هذه
الجريمه يعني القانون الامريكي يعني قائمه
وتدينه للرئيس ترامب على الاقل لكن الى
الان هو لازال في دائره يعني سوف يمثل
كمتهم
عليه اثبات براءته بموجب القانون الامريكي
بالتالي
الاتهام الذي وجه الى الرئيس ترامب والذي
متعلق بالمدفوعات التي دفعها خلال حمله
الانتخابيه
للممثله التي جنسيه معها
لا شك لا يمنع رئيس الامريكي او الساده من
الترشح
للالتهابات الرئاسيه القادمه لقانون
الامريكي لا يحضر عليه ذلك ولا يمنعه من
ذلك حتى وان تم ادانته بالتاليه
وهو داخل السجن في حاله ادانته طيب ممكن
ان تستغرق محاكمه رئيس ترامب حتى اصدار
الحكم النهائي بحقه في تقديرك
التصريحات التي صدرت عن يعني فريق
القانونيه الرئيس ترامب اتهموا القضاء في
ولايه نيويورك بانه قضاء متحيز ولم يصلوا
حتى يعني يعني وصلت توقعاتهم الى حد حتى
اذا انت رئيس ترامب عندما اتهموا هذا
القباب بانه القضاء غير نزيه الاتهام
الرئيس ترامب يعني ان الخطوات القانونيه
سوف تتابع اعتقد ان هذه القضيه يمكننا
اعتبارها اي انها ابسط القضايا التي
يواجهها الرئيس ترامب
جنائيه هناك قضايا اخرى تحضر له بالتالي
اعتقد هذه القضيه هي القضيه الاولى وسوف
يتبعها قضايا اخرى متعلقه
بعده امور اخرى بتوجهت له اتهامات يعني
انتخابات او التدخل في الانتخابات
الاجراءات عام 2020 اضافه لقضايا يعني
اخرى قد ايضا يوجه له لائحه اتهاماتها
اعتقد ان هذه القضيه سوف يتبعها قضايا
اخرى ومتاعب قانونيه اخرى سوف تلاحق رئيس
السابق
القانوني نعم اذا سنكتفي بهذا القدر شكرا
لك على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل مع
الباحث في الشؤون القانونيه فراس الحاجه
حياه السيد فاس
ومشاهدينا نتابع معكم هذه الصور المباشره
من برج ترامب الذي يقيم فيه الرئيس دونالد
ترامب الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب الذي
وصل مساء الاثنين الى نيويورك حيث يخطط
انصاره لتنظيم تجمع حاشد صباح اليوم
ونشاهد في هذه الصور ايضا الحواجز الامنيه
ورجال الشرطه الذين
يحيطون بهذا المكان تحسبا لاي توترات
امنيه قد تحدث مع قرب محاكمه الرئيس او
مثوله امام القاضي المحكمه العليا في
منعاه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب قبل
وصوله مشاهدينا كتب ترامب على منصته
للتواصل الاجتماعي
حمله اضطهاد ودولتنا التي كانت عظيمه في
يوم من الايام تتجه الى الجحيم كل ذلك
مشاهدينا ياتي وسطها استنفار امني كبير في
محيطي محكمه نيويورك حيث سيمثل الرئيس
الامريكي السابق عصر اليوم الثلاثاء امام
محكمه منحاه
لابلاغه رسميا
تهم جنائيه اليه في قضيه دفع اموال
الممثله الاباحيه
بغرض شراء صمتها وذلك ايضا مشاهدينا في
حدث غير مسبوق رئيس امريكي سابق
اذا مشاهدينا محاكمه ترامب تسبب توترات
على الساحه السياسيه الامريكيه وسط
مخاوفها من تصعيد امني في منهات شبيه
بحادثه الكابيتول في واشنطن
مع اختلاف طبيعه مثول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه بتهم
جنائيه واحداث الكابيتول الا ان هناك
مخاوف من تكرار ذات السيناريو فوضى وعنف
وتخريب رغم ان مؤشرات ذلك قليله وفقا
للسلطات الامنيه الامريكيه لكن لمعرفه
الاختلافات بين المناسبتين يجب اولا
التذكير باحداث الكابيتول
شغب الكابيتول حدث عام 2021 حين اقدم حشد
عنيف من انصار الرئيس دونالد ترامب على
مهاجمه مبنى الكابيتول في العاصمه واشنطن
احداث فتحت معها اكبر تحقيق في تاريخ
وزاره العدل الاميركي ويواجه اكثر من 930
شخصا اتهامات بارتكاب جرائم فيدراليه
الامر المشترك ما بين احداث الكابيتول
وبين مثول ترامب امام المحكمه بقضايا
جنائيه هو خطاب الرئيس الامريكي السابق
لمناصريه لكن المختلف هو توقيت الخطابين
في احداث الكابيتول كان خطابه ناريا
ظهر فيه قبل ساعات من الواقعه واثار
المئات من انصاره اما فيما يتعلق بمحاكمته
في منهات فاعلن الرئيس الامريكي انه سيظهر
علنا بخطاب لكن هذه المره بعد ساعات من
سماعه لائحه الاتهام الموجهه له فحوى
الخطاب غير معروفه حتى الان لكن المعروف
هو تاثير ترامب على انصاره وفي المقابل
ردات الفعل غير المتوقعه للمناهضين له
احداث الكابيتول مثلت درسا للسلطات
الامنيه بدات بعدها بمسح امني واسع
للمشاركين وتبادل المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
بشكل اسرع وعلى الارض تجهيز مواقع الحدث
بحواجز معدنيه واغلاق الطرق وحتى قوه
بشريه ضخمه تغطي مساحه واسعه استعدادا لاي
طارئ
[تصفيق]
مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
الدفاع البريطانيه تقول ان قيادات الجيش
الروسي تخطط لانشاء شركات عسكريه خاصه
توازي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد قالت وزاره
الدفاع البريطانيه الى الخلافات بين
قيادات الجيش الروسي ومجموعه فاغنا تدفع
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه الى التفكير في
انشاء ورعايه شركات عسكريه خاصه واضافت في
بيانها اليومي ان الدفاعات الروسيه ترى
انشاء شركات عسكريه خاصه وارسال عناصرها
الى اوكرانيا سيكون اكثر فائده بالنسبه
للجيش النظامي وان المجتمع الروسيه سيتقبل
خسائرها بشكل افضل مقارنه بالخسائر
العسكريه للجيش بدوره قال وزير خارجيه
اصبح معاديا وخسر روسيا معتبرا ان موسكو
ستتعامل مع اوروبا بطريقه قاسيه اذا لزم
الامر اضاف ايضا ان زعماء الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعلنون صراحه انه من الضروري
الحاق هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا كما اكد
لافاروف ان بلاده قررت كيفيه ردي على
تزويد اوروبا للنظام الاجرامي في كييف
بالاسلحه والمدربين على حد وصفه مشيرا الى
انه ردا على الخطوه العدائيه فان موس كو
ستتصرف بقسوه اذا لزم الامر بناء على
مصالحها الوطنيه ومبدا المعامله بالمثل
المقبول في الممارسات الدبلوماسيه
ياتي كل ذلك فيما نفس سفير
الروسيا
الاتحادت باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه واصفا
هذه المزاعم بانها دعايه تحريضيه ضد موسكو
نتابع
نحن لا نطالب بالحرب النوويه ولا نهدد بها
الروايه القائله بان روسيا تهدد العالم
بالاسلحه النوويه هي جزء من الدعايه ضد
روسيا لقد قلنا منذ وقت طويل ان العقيده
العسكري الروسيه تنص على حالات قليله جدا
حول امكانيه استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
قال وزير خارج الاوكراني فانه طالب مفوض
الشؤون الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيفوري بالعمل على تسريع خطط تزويد كياب
الذخيره واشار في تغريده له الى انه بحث
مع بوريل في بوركس الاتصالات القائمه بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي والصين وكان الاتحاد
الاوروبي اقر الشهر الماضي خطه لشراء
مليون طلقه من ذخيره مدفعيه لاوكرانيا
خلال العام المقبل
مشاهدينا الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا بك محمد
معنا في هذه النشره وبدايه هناك حديث عن
هجوم روسي بسبعه عشره طائره مسيره على
ميناء اوديسا ماذا لدينا من معلومات
وتفاصيل حول هذا الهجوم ومدى الضرر الذي
لحق به المنطقه المستهدفه ايضا
سبعه عشر مسيره ايرانيه استطاع
ت اربعه
اسود وايضا استطاعت يعني الكرات
الاوكرانيه تحييد 14 مسيره مما ايه وايضا
ثلاثه مسيرات سقطوا داخل يعني ميناء اوديس
البحري ولكن الاضرار كانت طفيفه جدا الجيش
الاوكراني يستمر والقوات يعني الجويه
تستمر انذار الجوي في عدد من المناطق في
جنوب اوكرانيا تحسبا لقيام روسيا ضربات
صاروخيه او اطلاق مسيرات لانه يعني خلال
الفتره الماضيه او خلال الاسبوعين او
الشهرين الماضيين عندما تكون روسيا
باستهداف ليلي عبر المسيرات تليها ضربات
صاروخيه في اليوم التالي لذلك هناك استن
فر لماذا جرى استهداف هذا الميناء تحديدا
ميناء اوديستام الذي يمثله بالنسبه للروس
ومكتسبهم الاهميه ايضا
يعني مدينه اوس
ا ولكن يعني خلال
سنه وشهر على الحرب لم تستطع روسيا
الاقتراب من اوديسا سوى عبر ضربات صاروخيه
وايضا ميناء اوديسا له
قيمه الميناء الوحيد الذي يعمل حاليا على
تقدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر الاتفاقيه
التي وقعت في رعايه الامم المتحده بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا برعايه تركيا او تنفيذ
تركيا ورعايته الامم المتحده ايضا يعني
المعالم الرئيسيه والاهم من اهم المعالم
الاوكرانيه حيث يعتبر المدخل الاقتصادي
ليس فقط لاوكرانيا بل للدول المجاوره
نعم طيب محمد سؤال ايضا فيما يتعلق
بتصريحات الروسيه المتناقضه بشان باخم
وهناك الجيش الروسي يتحدث عن عدم احراز
التقدم الارض وهناك ايضا تصريحات متناقضه
من قائد الذي يؤكد انه سيطر على المبنى
الاداري للمدينه او مبنى اداره المدينه ما
الذي يحدث في بخمه محمد بحسب الروايه
الاخرانيه تحديدا
حتى هذه اللحظه وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
تؤكد ان القتال مستمر داخل المدينه
الباخمه وان القوات الاوكرانيه تدافع وتصب
الهجوم الروسي الكبير وايضا بالامس يعني
وهو قائد القوات البريه للجيش الاوكراني
كان داخل مدينه
او الحي الرئيسي او حي الوسط يعني في
مدينه ضخمه واكد ان القتال مستمر وان
القوات الاوكرانيه تقاتل وانه من الصعب
يعني في الوقت الحالي ان تقوم روسيا
بالسيطره بشكل كامل على مدينه ولكن
المعارك بحسب ما يصلنا هي معارك شرسه جدا
تبادل كثيف للفصل بين الطرفين بين الجانب
الاوكراني والجانب الروسي الجيش الاوكراني
يقصف مراكز تجمع القوات الروسيه القوات
الروسيه ومجموعات تغير بشكل كبير وعنيف
جدا على وسط مدينه ضخمه لاحتلاله ولكن
يعني احد الضباط العسكريين او متحدث
قال ان حتى هذه اللحظه لا يمكن تاكيد ان
تكون القوات الروسيه قد سيطرت على المبنى
الرئيسي لمدينه كنت معنا الصحفي محمد
البابا شكرا لك محمد على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل
نفذت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه ضربه
جويه في شمال غرب سوريا امس اسفرت عن مقتل
خالد عيد احمد الجبوري احد كبار قاده داعش
واوضح بيان القياده المركزي الامريكيه ان
الضربه لم تتسبب في سقوط قتل او جرحى في
المنطقه مؤكده ان مقتل الجبوري سيعطل
مؤقتا قدره التنظيم على التخطيط لهجمات
خارجيه كونه مسؤولا عن التخطيط لهجمات
داعش في اوروبا وتطوير قياده شبكه التنظيم
مشاهدي البريطانيه ينضموا الينا مدير
المرصد السوري لحقوق اثار امير عبد الرحمن
اهلا بك في هذه النشره وبدايه ما اهم
المعطيات التي توفرت لكم بخصوص هذه
العمليه وفي اي منطقه في الداخل السوري
نفذت
نعم صباح الخير هي نفذت في شمال ادلب
ونشرت امس عبر العربيه وعبر الحدث عن
استهداف طائره يرجح بانها للتعارف الدولي
لرجل في ريف ادلب الشمالي الدالي مقتله
على على طريق بيار
في تلك المنطقه استهدف استاجر الرجل منزل
قبل ايام وقيل لاوقال لاهالي المنطقه بانه
ولاجئ او ناجحه الى هذه المنطقه في ادلب
هربا من النظام او هربه من قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه لكن الواضح بان يعني كان
عندما استهدف كان يسير خارج المنزل ويتحدث
بالجوال وايجابيات طائره مسيره امريكيه
تستهدفه وتقتله بشكل مباشر طبعا لم يبطل
معه اي شخص على الاطلاق لوحده في المنتصف
او الاستهداف الامريكي الذي طالبه ولكن
لماذا وكيف علمت امريكا بوجوده
استهدف وكيف سكن بهذه المنطقه وما هي
الاهميه ايضا التي يحظى بها
الجبوري داخل التنظيم حتى يستهدف
قطع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عندما
تستهدف شخص في ادلب او في مناطق السيطره
التركيه او اي منطقه لا تستهدف يعني مقاتل
عادي في التنظير تستهدف قيادات الصف الاول
بالتنظيم هذا الرجل هو قيادي من الصف
الاول بالتنظيم ولكن كيف تواجد في هذه
المنطقه من المفترض بانها ممسوكه امنيا
بشكل كبير جدا من قبل الامنيين
الجولاني لذلك اقول بان هناك من اعطى
المعلومات في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
عن تحركاته كي يستهدف بهذه السهوله بعد
ايام تواجده في هذه المنطقه وجميع من
حول اهميه العاديه استخدام اجهزه الجوال
بالنسبه لقيادات داعش والقاعده في هذه
المناطق لانها الطريقه مكشوفه بالتاكيد
وتؤدي الى مخاطر امنيه بالنسبه لهذه
القيادات
هو كان يعتقد بانه غير معروف ويتكلم
اللهجه الديريه الغير بعيده عن لهجه يعني
غرب العراق اعتقد بانه انسان يعني من
المفترضني ولكن يستهدف الجوال ويتحدث
ويعيش حياته الطبيعيه هو اعتقد بانه يعيش
في منطقه امنه وبعيدا عن ترصد التحالف
الدولي ولكن الواضح بان مسلما نقول بان
هناك على الارض من اعطى احداثياته للتحرك
الدوله القياده المركزيه تقول ان الضربه
نفذت بشكل احادي هل يعني ذلك انها لم تنسق
مع اي من شركائها المحليين
على الاطلاق هي
نفذ الامر لم يحتاج الى طائرات مروحيه ولم
يحتاج الى عمليه
تحتاجها فقط الى المسيره التي قتلته بشكل
مباشر عند استهدافه شكرا لك لمدينتي
البريطانيه كنت معنا مدير المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن
نشاطنا مستمرا مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
تايوان ترصد اقتراب 20 مقاتله وثلاث سفن
حربيه تابعه للصين
[موسيقى]
يواجه ثلاثه وثلاثين تهاما امام محكمه
نيويورك ومحامه يعتبر قضيته اضطهادا
سياسيا
هو رئيس الدوما يتهم الغرب بتحويل
اوكرانيا الى دوله ارهابيه
غاره امريكيه في سوريا تستهدف قياديا
كبيرا في تنظيم داعش خطط لتنفيذ هجمات في
اوروبا
الصين تهدد بلقاء رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي رئيسه تايوان في كاليفورنيا
وتحذر من التداعيات
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد عبرت الصين عن
معارضتها لزياده لزياره رئيسه تايوان الى
الولايات المتحده للقاء رئيس مجلس النواب
الامريكي كيفن الاجتماع المغتربه بانه
استفزازي وسيضر العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه اكثر وشدد المتحدث باسم
القنصليه الصينيه في ولايه لوس انجلوس
الامريكيه ان هذا اللقاء المنتظر سيجرح
مشاعر اكثر من مليار صيني كونه يخرب بل
يخرب ويضعف قاعده اساس العلاقات الصينيه
بين بكين واشنطن حسب قوله وباسم مبدا صين
واحده ترى بكين انه يفترض ان لا تقيم اي
دوله علاقات رسميه
في وقت واحد في المقابل اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع في تايوان رصد اقتراب 20 طائره
وثلاث سفن تابعه للجيش الصيني بالخط منتصف
الفاصل في مضيق تايوان وقالت الوزاره انها
ارسلت دوريات جويه او بحريه لمراقبه الوضع
ونشرت انظمه صواريخ ارضيه لمواجه ه ما
وصفته بالتهديد الصيني
في سياق اخر مشاهدينا قالت الخارجيه
الصينيه ان اقامه قواعد عسكريه جديده
لواشنطن في فلبين سيؤدي لمزيد من التصعيد
ورافت الى ان واشنطن تعزز من انتشارها
العسكري في المنطقه وتزعزع استقارها
واوضحت بكين انها تعارض بشده اي اجتماع
بين اي مسؤول امريكي وساي وتعاهدت بدفاع
عن سياده الصين كما ذكرت الخارجيه الصينيه
ان دخول المنطاد الصيني لاجواء امريكا كان
حادثا مدنيا غير متوقع متابع
او قواعد عسكريه امريكيه جديده في الفلبين
تثير غضب الصين
والتي تسعى للهيمنه على المنطقه بحسب
واشنطن
الا ان القواعد الامريكيه الجديده تعيق
الاهداف الصينيه
القواعد الامريكيه تقع بمناطق استراتيجيه
فالقاعده البحريه في مقاطعه كاكايان تبعد
400 كم فقط عن تايوان
اما القاعده الاخرى فتقع في جزيره باليباك
بالقرب من بحر الصين الجنوبي ليكون عدد
القواعد الامريكيه في الفلبين تسعه قواعد
كما يتم التفاوض بشان قاعده امريكيه عاشره
محتمله
مشاهدينا تنشطوا في رمضان في المغرب ظاهره
دوريات الاحياء السكنيه المصغره لكره
القدم فانديه الاحياء تخوض مواجهات كرويه
بشكل يومي قبيل رفع اذان المغرب في تقليد
رمضاني مغربي تاريخي نتابع
[موسيقى]
في امسيه رمضانيه مواجهه ساخنه بين خمسه
لاعبين في مواجهه خمسه اخرين في مباراه في
دوري بين الاحياء السكنيه في مدينه سلا
المغربيه تلعب كل دمك شاركو
ماهر من اي بلاصه
والحمد لله حنا فرحانين
اولاد الحومه
ديما قبل الفطور ان شاء الله
يناديه تلاميذه في كره القدم بعمي حسن هو
الرئيس المؤسس للجمعيه الحسنيه في سلا
الجديده مدرب ومنظم للدوريات الكرويه
المصغره بين الاحياء السكنيه منذ عشرين
عاما
كنديروها الدوري هذا
رمضاني باش كنبعدم الاخطار
مهمه للانسان احنا كنعقلوا
لاعبين موقعين
مشارف كبير
في حي اخر في مدينه سلا وعلى بعد نصف ساعه
من رفع اذان المغرب في يوم رمضاني تتواصل
بحماس اطوار مباراه بين عشاق الساحره
المستديره بين ناديين محليين سلايين يجد
مغاربه متعه في المشاركه في دوريات
رمضانيه لكره القدم دوريات تجري مبارياتها
في الساعات الاخيره من يوم الصيام عادل
الزبيري العربيه مدينه سلا بقرب العاصمه
المغربيه الرباط
[موسيقى]
وقبل الختام مشاهدينا نذكر بابرز العناوين
محكمه نيويورك ومحاميه يعتبر قضيته
اضطهادا سياسيا
يتهم الغرب بتحويل اوكرانيا الى دوله
ارهابيه
غاره امريكيه في سوريا تستهدف قياديا
كبيرا في تنظيم داعش خطط لتنفيذ هجمات في
اوروبا
الصين تهدد بلقاء رئيس مجلس
تايوان في كاليفورنيا وتحذر من التداعيات
نهايه
[موسيقى]